ouais assieds toi faut que je te parle
d'exil
j'ai passé ma journée dans le noir qui
je le sais je le sens jusqu'ici il se
fout de moi j'arrête c'est manu nous
aime manu m'a dit sénèque la france
c'est une reine je pourrais trouver pour
elle il faut pas se paniquer sur le mec
assure de ma 4e le web le mec est pur il
ne trompe pas dans ce sens mais tu sais
pas toi ça fait des semaines qu'il m'en
fais chez moi me laisse des messages
deux fois par mois
mal-aimé olympia manu souvient de
michael ouais quoi tout ça dans ma la
preuve formelle il dit pour cours à
sortir à partir du 11 mai mais ptet sa
changera qu on devra tous porter des
masques comme chewbacca que ça nous
protégera ou pas ça on ne sait pas mais
qu'il est fier londres à côté de la
plaque 3 de man u avait rappelé en moi
qu'après le confinement qu'on pourrait
regarder de partir comme un bon break my
way n'a pas démontré red bull est pas
repro masquer le vrai tu parlais de mes
couilles escaro pas les voir
je ne sais pas si je peux sortir et a
calé en quarts si on y va en courant
alors c'est après 19 heures mais si on y
va maintenant est ce que faire prendre
un chien avec moi je n'étais plus moi me
vois le ska pop qui se retrouve c'est
pas ça moi ma fille m'a dit t'es vu
quand je l'appelle sapn jean la trêve ça
pénètre commencer par tant sur la veille
samedi m6 avait quitté l'arabie clip a
vu sur françois il nous a pas remis un
mois était encore en vie pour toi je ne
prête pas manu est égal à bâle où
c'était bien sa voix fait peut-être ya
eu 130 fois lors des quatre ans mâts
belgica pourquoi tout cas françois
laurin [ __ ] reprends toi arrête
d'appeler tous les mois pour savoir à
quels domaines doivent penser les
dieppois sont pas stopper l'engrenage
d'une les cadres
regarde moi après que des clichés croyez
plus depuis qu'il m'a parlé pas lui
jeter le bandeau rappelons qu'il croyait
maquettes et modèles optiques comme tu
te pas grave
la direction d un pacs a jamais prouvé
avoir réparé guy encore assis toi faut
que je te parle moi si tu vas passer tes
journées dans noir
ar oui je le sais je le sens j'en suis
sûr il se fout de toi